citizens of the reject give me my
present give me my birthday present yeah
hello Michael gave me your best and he
put it together himself I did it was
really hard I believe that I put one
together and I broke it yeah that is a
four week it was rough this is amazing
thank you I'm gonna pull a Harrison
forward George thing and just smash
ladies and Gentlemen please follow our
Star Wars Aficionado MJ tests are on
social media they'll be very much
appreciated and thank you guys for
watching our videos last week's was a
hit and loved the episode so it really
pays off when you love the episode go
ahead leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated as always full and threats
and watch along where you sing it with
your own copy of Ahsoka available for
super sexy rejects over supper stuff
exclusively over there we got a sponsor
sponsors do help out especially with the
plethora of host real rejects now has
along with any additional editing help
we get you know how it goes let's roll
that sponsor want to give a shout out to
the masterminds at Goat games creators
of some of the hottest RPGs in the
mobile today they bring us another gem
bloodline Heroes of lead us
oh
in bloodline you'll build a kingdom and
collect Champions to defend it the
coolest Parts craft your very own
Legendary Champions by blending
Bloodlines of elves demons Orcs and so
many more it's free to play just hit the
link in the description box or scan the
QR code right here immersed in a mobile
game like never before Mary Bloodlines
creating thousands of hybrid champions
ever thought about mixing a lichen in
Dragonborn now you can plus they're
insane Guild Wars events and nail
fighting arena battles meet the tide
razors Fierce demigods in the darkest
Seas my personal favorite the vampire
Clan dive Vela here's lion Stone a tank
Champion is an absolute Beast all right
so some juicy stuff number one download
now for free on Android and iOS use my
link below or scan the QR code to grab a
starter pack worth 20 with my link we're
talking summoning Crystal heaps of gold
and diamonds three first 30 to drop
their account ID and username below
you're snagging a free legendary female
succubus Champion the luxuriant so don't
wait dive into bloodline Heroes will
leave us and let the adventure begin
thank you again for sponsoring this
video we should have thrawn this time
right maybe
thrawn or Ezra I'm gonna throw my hat in
the ring for we see Ezra both I'm gonna
go both
because then you'll win one way or
another
whoa
Intergalactic hyperspace travel looks
sick
trippy so psychedelic my God it's full
of stars this is what happens when you
had the death sticks took a lactic
travel within a star whale
now I really have done it all
I remember them from the stories you
would tell us when you were a child
building a lightsaber I still have those
stories in my archive memory would you
like to hear one yes oh yes please lore
dump it not right now she went with the
Enemy willingly impossible I saw it
through the force when I held the map
wow
that is troubling you don't seem
concerned buddy I'm convinced who Yang
is force sensitive
anybody can be you know to the new Star
Wars force runs through all living
things she was fated to make that choice
that wasn't
enough time to prepare her to make the
right one not Destiny don't forget
Paul's provides you with Insight but it
does not give one only answers the house
for Sabine it was the only choice hmm a
choice she made for herself
that is your fear
you can't control her second thought
tell me one of those stories Laura we're
not going to hear it Michael a long time
ago
in a galaxy yes
the first time her characters actually
said it at least in live action right
yeah that's wait guys lovely title title
which means I never properly decipher
what they mean
[Music]
it's perfect it's everything
I was hoping for a room with a view
best view in the house I would think
this would be an opportunity for
reflection I try to avoid that I can
understand why there are no mirrors we
had a deal
you promised me I would see Ezra again
it takes time to get there careful all
your words the prisoner
is impatient
the focus to find Ezra Bridge you're
blinds her
I believe she can still be of some use
to us how so
thank you for Flying Star Tours
for visual yeah uh what is it gonna look
like
like space okay the final frontier oh
cool oh that's sick that is the ancient
Homeworld of my ancestors yes that's
exactly what I was thinking that's what
I said let's get witchy migration route
used by the star whales as they Traverse
the void from one galaxy to the others
among the first to harness and ride the
creatures in the days before time was
counted history wow wow the whales came
here to die peridia
dude you're killing it next season it'll
be me let us not keep them waiting
interesting
oh I'm I'm so excited
the nice sisters know how to build some
cool looking chips wait till you see
their graveyard
it only made sense because I'm like how
would thrawn be communicating and all
that and know to talk to her why would
she want to go right yeah no the
alliance is beginning to make much more
sense and in the weapon against the
greater adversary
oh man it's like the statues and Lord of
the Rings
I love how they're keeping it in this
perspective it's like when you're on a
plane and you're like what is it is that
the Grand Canyon
holy moly nothing uncomfortable about
that the mouths on these things Jesus
that's what he said oh she's so happy
it's home but like culturally what
happens when you're separated by an
entire galaxy for that long
my ship is pure gold
thrawn with his mimosa you think we'll
see him this soon or is it loud no I
think all right Sisters Let's Get witchy
come on
oh this is so exciting for Star Wars
oh wow
oh it's a ghost concert
keep it together Morgan
oh my God oh my God right at me welcome
child of Darth oh wow the echo do our
ancestors credit thank you great mother
great mother you heard our call to you
in the dream oh Visions guided me across
the Stars oh that's right
and UK has thrown promise where is
thrawn you shall wait he is coming
they're talking to us in episode 8 he
will be here it reeks of Jedi
oh look at the wrong people it is
dangerous
yeah historically speaking
oh
I am so into this right now
it's another training exercise close
your eyes
oh
it will wait in solitude
hey we had a deal where is Ezra
where is he Ezra's word you're going
right now
is the reunion I feel it do you feel it
feels so soon
we're an episode
we're almost done with this Michael this
is our time it's gonna be on the other
side of the wall
oh
are those loathables I I mean I can't
imagine those are loath wolves but they
look like wolves
this is phenomenal I mean lothballs have
the capability of
it's true they do have some Force
sensitivity going on
is a fascinating
series of events for him
fit in I think he's bored
I thought we'd be more into our plan by
now this is a land of dreams and Madness
children's stories come to life it is a
silly place I know no such stories no
when I was a bit older than you are now
[Music]
I watched everything I knew burn
the Jedi Temple oh it's the first time
she's hearing this look at history you
realize it's all inevitable Thanos
follow the Jedi rise of the empire all
great titles it repeats again and again
always with some New Hope break the
wheel what I seek
so I may finally bring this cycle to an
end yeah I I love them together I know
in the beginning is here
if the old stories are true
God it sucks that he died yeah
I'm sad there can't be like a spin-off
about the two of them yeah for so many
reasons and just watching this you're
like what am I doing respond Ezra
part of me wonders if there's other Jedi
in this galaxy maybe he's found his
place among them or he's just a nomad
oh what if Ezra becomes she becomes
patawanda him in some way all right
Maybe
do this fear is the mind killer come on
this place is too dark
everything no damn it
I think thrawn's arriving the amount of
misleading they do with her in the force
yeah it's brilliant playing chicken with
us
with someone sort of make an impression
hell yeah glad to see he got it fixed up
I know pergo's Captain intact yo that's
sick
you can kind of see where some parts
might have been fixed oh look at the
symbols
this would have been cool on a big
screen I'll tell you
Maybe
ah yeah you can see that's cool
wow the scale of that
oh boy the Benny Jesuit were right
thrawn's here
just miss me he's got a whole Warby it
sure does
whoa
whoa I bet that guy's gonna amount to
not much
oh they're chanting his name
nice frame
wow hey that looks really cool and he's
probably gonna be no one
great music
again Jesus just elements of thrawn's
theme wow he looks so good what was
first just a dream has become a
frightening reality I love that they got
him for those who may impose us
great mothers I salute you
hell yeah this is Enoch captain of my
God he shall begin the cargo transfer
Enoch I have seen the catacombs
it will take some time
at least three rotations that's three
days
oh he knows he knows who that prisoner
is he never spoke of this
she could be of some use to us and you
are real in school and you must be
General
general of the Jedi Order
I bought advice with the Jedi long ago
they serve together you wouldn't be the
first
is that a food to Ezra no there's a
familiar name yes yeah did she bring art
with her she'll be of great use to us
bargain too
boy this is a fun Reunion yeah so Grim
so ominous
thrawn
what a delight it is after so long to
see a familiar face
wow I understand it is you I have to
thank for my escape from exile
where is Ezra
the desire to be reunited with your long
lost friend
oh that singular Focus would reshape our
galaxy just answer the question
no need for hostility
I'm aware of your agreement with Ben and
skull and I intend to on right of course
you do you shall have Provisions amounts
and our latest Intel on British
whereabouts oh so you're just on the
planet alone you helped my course
now I shall help yours
brilliant once My Starship departs
you'll be strategy forever that's fine
it's also quite possible that your
friend
is dead
um if you survived I'm sure he's doing
just fine
you wouldn't understand
perhaps not
oh boy oh you're not loads wolves
either way
filling in the missing armor with gold
and the Japanese style yeah Roman
gladiator they call that Kitsune
so that night Troopers are culturally
appropriating Japanese culture that's
already the first time in Star Wars have
you heard that Jedi no man's wander this
Wasteland and Prey Upon each other for
survival is a nomad Mad Max World kind
of feel like they're sending her die
well
bars so that they can find him
you think we're doing you a solid when
really you're doing us solid I feel like
I'm watching Game of Thrones right now
yeah she's riding out north of the wall
Dune of Thrones
without desolate
this actually does feel like Lord of the
Rings you may follow her I thought you
were to honor your agreement yes to
catch Bridger so being written will have
the opportunity of finding Ezra Bridge
here just as promised
and if she does eight vote you and your
master will destroy them both
loopholes will get you I think Ezra
could probably whoop their asses so
curious what Ezra is like at this
particular point in time I think he's
probably grown exceptionally more
powerful over time
steady
I wonder if the beginning was the only
time we see Ahsoka
I love the contrast
oh damn use the freaking force my dude
nice helmet I love new species
come on
exactly
oh yeah oh yeah how's that Mandalorian
say who you're looking for oh they're
gonna see that that's gonna
wait yes
oh
it's a great fight for her
nice
porn you win
kind of reminiscent of the Tuscan
Raiders but the way that creature looked
at the lightsaber there was a sense of
familiarity yeah
all right I'm sorry bailing riding on
them this is so freaking cool God the
Symmetry and it does feel like a much
more ancient part of the Galaxy should
we not send more troops to support them
during this Exile and numbers have
dwindled so no two squats will suffice
God I cannot get over that they brought
him away he's so good he's perfect
objective is to escape this galaxy
matters not whether Ren and Bridge are
killed the saying can be set for you too
Mastery it's gonna be crazy I wish
they'd been away with this outfit also
did he just say he wants to wipe out
I may I guess we'll have that Jedi turn
well that creates an interesting
Alliance you
all right
should have known you were a coward yeah
all the things she wants to say to us
okay
Walks Like A direwolf
I feel like a volume okay fine
I'll give you another chance but you
better not bail on me this time got it
I love how threatening this creature
looks at first is actually so friendly
it's a metaphor for this whole side of
the Galaxy
under a rock here embarrassing yourself
come on Jedi lift The Rock
this is speaking character okay yeah
that Trick's over oh hermit crab guy
get up come on I can see you there
can you creep
oh it's so exciting
[Music]
actually it kind of reminds me of the uh
Jedi Survivor no this little fella
this guy from Men In Black little
crustacean
oh he has a cute little outfit
no it won't hurt you do you understand I
understand everybody
it's really cute
no
is there a toy available yet to buy
voice
in Franklin
oh he knows the symbol yeah
oh hell yes impossible you know how it's
possible oh it has a little community
[Music]
Ezra befriending the animals yeah I
expect nothing less I mean these aren't
quite animals they're a civilization of
sentient well-dressed let's go rock
trolls from Frozen Do You Know Ezra
Bridger he's my friend
do you know the one she seeks so
desperately It's Too Young comes from a
breed of Balkan Jedi
you
I train to be something more
preferred Jedi Jedi Pro Plus Max do you
mess up the order miss the benefits the
idea of it hmm
but not the truth
the weakness there was no future there
so many of these orders I see what once
was the great witch Kingdom of the death
Mary standing on the rubble of greatness
they seem eager to leave this place they
flee a power
greater than their own
that's the crisp finally the flee a
fixer-upper something calls to me
can't you hear it can't you see it I see
Bandits
huh yeah the enemy of our enemy is our
friend
for now perhaps and the way they frame
them together is perfect there's just
something so much bigger at play and I'm
so excited for it
did he build like a little village
he's so different looking than the
parents doesn't have a shell yet I gotta
go get a shot oh yeah yeah I hope that
they don't do anything to these people
I've got a bad feeling about that that's
way too happy right now I knew I could
count on you
hmm
[Music]
no it looks great hell yeah no
sure took you long enough
classic you didn't
tell any of us where you were going
that's because I didn't know where I was
going always a plan
never a good one hey
it worked didn't it classic banter
between them didn't it
oh he doesn't know it it worked
[Music]
wow
they make baby do it right here
consecrate the reunion
it's a sick outfit for him
look at that mail I see my friends found
you
yeah
your very own band of rebels
you're writing a Hound how'd that happen
in fact how did you find me
how did you get here let's not talk
about that that feels important hey I
just want to be happy that I found you
after all this time can I have that
audience have that of course
then bailing comes in slaughtered
the women the children turn them into a
clambake Sabine
[Music]
thanks for coming can't wait to go home
it's pretty great casting man it really
does he's right on the money yeah made
him look grown up in the right kind of
ways They Ride The Travelers
well that is unwelcome news
to our eyeballs and Jedi could it be the
recently deceased so katana
impossible hmm I thought it was beyond
you
have to underestimate a Jedi Ron knows
better death and Resurrection are common
deceptions played out by both nice
sister and Jetta
[Laughter]
not yet
he was once a Jedi
we must regarding this floor run rings
around you logically we shall consider
alive until we know otherwise finally a
character brain I wish I'd prepare
accordingly I want to know her
background history home World her master
everything what kind of art she likes if
a star whale approaches Meridia
destroyed with prejudice
say some racist before you do it I
should once again require the eight
of your dark magic yes let's go the
thread of Destiny demands it
let's go
all right
looks like Robert Patrick a little bit
it's a little Vladimir Putin too in his
face
so Sarah going for boy
blue Putin I was well directed too all
righty well I want to mention something
that if we do have like a real rejects
podcast and so if you are listening to
this on you know Apple Spotify whatever
it may be please rate it that would
really help us out a lot and also I did
not mention this at the top probably
should have thank you to everyone who's
been buying shirts from the real rejects
apparel man it's been it's been really
awesome to see your guys's support right
now I'm wearing my uh you know the
protection services
I love this film of course we've had our
Soaker shirts a lot of you guys been
buying that as well we got a bunch of
other apparel and working on a new
Ahsoka shirt right now and it's almost
done it's almost done I think you guys
are really gonna like it I I really love
that one but anyway let's talk about the
episode all right who goes first how
about this let's wait by this scale okay
John
um uh Cold Stone's Creamery of rank it
what what would you say really quick
I'll go through everyone between like it
love it and Gotta Have It
um I guess it's a love it then all right
you know all right Michael
um it's the the birthday cake flavor and
like could they add some cookie oh uh
we're going by the increments of this oh
I'm making my order yeah I felt cookies
and cream about this episode you know
what I mean a few nuts a cherry maybe no
I I think this was a it was the perfect
opening to something new which is the my
favorites
do you like it or love it or gotta have
it or you I gotta have it okay okay so
that's the highest ranking yeah I gotta
have it and I love it yeah and I like it
thank you
all right
and uh I would say I I nah I I gotta
have it yeah I gotta have it I I know I
feel pressured this this is a I I really
I really like this one a lot
um this is one of the best ones yeah
yeah so um John considering your uh
overwhelming praise was not as high as
whatever Michael was doing uh well you
go first man yeah I mean this in the
previous episode certainly feel like
they have a a fluidity of momentum that
naturally comes one into the other and I
you know again as the least uh
comprehensively knowledgeable person in
this room this episode related the Star
Wars or in general in general across
life yeah certain Star Wars as well this
episode uh really did a nice thing for
me which was it did feel like it was
taking advantage of that gradual
deliberate and pensive tone that this
show particularly wants to you put
forward but also it felt like it was
applying that tone in just the right
amount to exploration and to uh setting
up suspense and to all of the flavors
they were hoping to build so the only
reason I felt kind of short of being
like I gotta have it is because I'm at
that point where I'm like especially
again as of these two episodes I'm like
this is cooking and I'm really enjoying
the progression we're making even the
arrival of thrawn the arrival of Ezra
those are things that certainly probably
mean more to you but to me still got me
excited still got me worried I mean you
know we've had all these issues and
these shows of things being set up well
and maybe not being paid off but for
right now the introduction of this new
big bad seeing this new side of the
world I was quite pulled in and dazzled
by a lot of that stuff and and yeah now
the only thing sort of I've learned with
these shows to be a little bit cautious
as to how they go about sticking their
Landings and paying things off but this
felt like the kind of episode that both
manages to give you not everything you
know it doesn't blow the load too soon
but this one actually does give you some
things you've been anticipating and it
does so whilst maintaining the gradual
tone they've got to think about Grandma
this this was very nicely pitched it was
very well balanced and I am just hoping
that they can maintain and continue to
build on this as we go that's really
funny uh all right yeah
um this part of the chapters in YouTube
video is is called uh General thoughts
or just Ahsoka episode six I don't I'm
not familiar with General thoughts well
we're gonna have chapters for like you
know thrawn on Ezra oh sure so so what
is your general review I mean my my
general thoughts are they took us to a
new Galaxy I think they successfully
achieved making us feel like we were in
a new Galaxy I really love that this one
is inspired a lot more heavily on like
Eastern culture uh and then particularly
like really leaning into some of the
more kind of mythological and and almost
Fantastical elements of Star Wars uh
what they did in terms of like
demonstrating how time has passed and
what they've done with like thrawn and
his people
I thought was just marvelous like
clearly Dave filoni like played Fallout
New Vegas and got some inspiration from
some of the sick uh Like Gladiator slash
like samurai-esque inspiration of uh of
the armor
um but it was it was new and refreshing
and it was nice to like see an alien
species that we didn't all know right
away
um and so almost in that moment of being
Lost in Translation uh and even like to
to your point
like as we were entering the Galaxy and
seeing it through the perspective of
them looking out the window it was nice
to have something just new
um so General thoughts are I'm like
super excited to see where this goes
yeah yeah I I loved I mean I agree with
everything you guys said I love the I
love the mood of it like I was just
vibing with this episode again that tone
which has been somewhat conflicting for
some audiences and then even for
ourselves in a couple of episodes where
it wasn't quite driving with us it's
very much applicable for stepping into
unknown terrain you know where
everything kind of feels like it could
be a threat of some kind and I think the
transportation to this new Galaxy is
really really cool I didn't quite yet
get I really feel like we just venture
to a new planet
um
I haven't quite I haven't quite got that
feeling of yeah you know crazy new
Galaxy it feels like yeah I need some
new reachers some new aliens and but but
the the point of it was to establish
like the ancient ruins and and I really
I really enjoyed that part of it and I
think the the build and setup of what's
to come is really exciting stuff I think
this is one of those episodes that can
be easy for some people perhaps to
criticize as well because because of the
build up to a new Galaxy and it is just
kind of barren Wasteland and you don't
really see much that feels like entirely
new yeah you know because a lot of it
feels like uh if anything it feels like
Multiverse version of some of the things
we kind of know already and our that was
that we've been familiar with
however it is just the first one and to
me what's more important is establishing
goals motivation character more than
aesthetic because if we were getting
more of that and less of character then
we'd be complaining about that
instead and I feel like what we got in
uh outweighs at all now let's really
talk about them and like good stuff
right well I think that's a perfect
segue uh if it's all right to talk about
thrawn yes uh
I'm chomping at the bit here when can I
go in there and talk about thrawn
or after this
after a word from our sponsor all right
thrawn and the Knight sisters
one chapter
we're gonna we're gonna bundle them up
for times like
they are trying to flee this galaxy yeah
and that to me is the most exciting part
of this entire story is that you have
like these like Sage elders and I love
how like they've really played into like
the fates from Greek mythology even with
like the threat like it's it's not so on
the nose
um it is the nose uh
there is something bigger and scarier
that they are fleeing from and I think
when you kind of recontextualize this
story and that the reason that the first
planet that we see is so dead and Barren
is because this is a Galaxy that is near
its end uh sets up something that is big
and different and exciting
um and I think also puts all of these
characters into a very very strange uh
predicament and I think like I've said
from the beginning like thrawn is one of
the most complex interesting characters
in Star Wars I hope that they do him
Justice
um just like seeing the transition from
animation to live action I mean it's
like beautiful other than in his outfit
which needs to go like everyone else got
a sweet New Deal and it's a common boy
yeah it's just something new
um but I get it like but
um Lars played him in yeah yeah and and
to have that uh continuity of character
and I thought his performance is just
yeah I won't get that with Rex
no
cause Rex is probably dead at this point
no I mean when Rex steered in The Flash
oh no I mean listen they got it they
were they were throwing us they were
throwing us bird seed and we took it and
ate it like happy little birds uh
because we're all pigeons and the
apolloni's world
um
put that on a planet uh pigeons
that's exactly it but no I mean thrawn's
gravitas I think he's like weird
cult-like thing that he's got going on
is really unique part of me wondered for
a minute because they were like very
very gung-ho about thrawn I mean like
saying his name is like he's like God
Emperor part of me wonders if the
dathomir which is have maybe used a
little of their magic to bring a little
extra obedience to the Troops because it
was a little cult-like
um and while thrawn is compelling him
I'm not quite convinced that he's like
God Emperor level
um
uh but yeah honestly I would love to
just like I mean they've been stranded
and they need a leader is he like the
Wilson volleyball to their Tom Hanks and
Castaway if that is the analogy you wish
to draw that's the only analysis
well and they've been exiled into a
place where magic and dark magic at that
is very much a thing yeah so I mean
maybe yeah I I'm
I would I would love I know we'll never
see it I would love to see like how the
separation from Ezra Bridger went down
uh when they first arrived in this place
and all of that I mean yeah we probably
won't but when we're talking about Ezra
remind me to
to say Greg what was that thing you want
to bring up sure I'm going to forget and
then uh that I'm honestly I remember
what that remind us in the comment
section
um but John I'm curious to get uh your
thoughts on because yes I think for for
for us familiar with what what they have
done is because like while they have the
books of thrawn and everything
bringing Lars Mickelson over
they have they're sent they are
continuing the exact like like while you
got whoever place of being Ren doing her
own rendition while you've got Rosario
Dawson doing her own Edition this is a
straight uh yeah this is a straight up
continuation from the animation into
here
um where where I I feel like perhaps
some of the makeup might get a little
bit criticized it's pretty bright uh you
know I said they have a kid that guy's
blue the guy like blue it's just I feel
like if you've seen the image it didn't
bother me having seen some images and
having heard him speak a few times
anything is better than the grand
Inquisitor in Obi-Wan sure yeah
uh but with with not as much familiarity
I would say uh what would you what what
was your impression of the villain that
we that they've been building up to this
whole time uh yeah it's certainly a
gradual one because he is so calm
collected in control but it was a very
intriguing start to that for me
especially given that he has this very
unique and very sort of imposing looking
Squadron of taped up sort of they almost
they almost feel like uh like uh oh God
I'm gonna blank the name but you know
like the army of the Dead in Lord of the
Rings or something like that you know
and and yeah there is that sort of like
cult level adherence that they might be
under or whatever but at least from here
I was sitting here going like
well this guy does seem like he has he
just carries himself with that level of
poise but also you can tell that there
is such sort of uh Power and desire
beneath the surface and such a kind of
Wheel of vision at least here right now
I thought this was a solid start a solid
setup because of course they're not I
didn't expect him to ever introduce him
with some kind of like huge violent
moment or anything like that I
understand this guy is at least supposed
to be cunning and supposed to be maybe
not just your average you know mustache
swirling Zealot and this was in line
with that and it definitely had me
curious and genuinely so to see where
the rest of this goes and it's also
bolstered by the fact that you've got
witches and and again these cool gold
you know riffs on Stormtroopers and
stuff yeah and when Michael and I were
first discussing thrano a few absolutely
we were like really debating I was like
no the guy's straight up a villain and a
lot of that is just like I I read
um oh my God
now's not a time to Blink
a book the comic at it I didn't read the
action
uh what the hell's the title of it Ron
this is just called The Rock that's the
name of the series and the army of
dunharrow those are those there's not a
subtype well there's the ascendancy uh
what was the one on the Marvel one that
they adapt they adopted straight from
the uh where it starts off where he gets
goes into like he's literally brought
over and he's talking about the chiz and
he has a lieutenant and yeah and he's on
the dark world it's uh it rises the
Rings yeah let's just go through it I
think it's just called thrawn thrawn
Ragnarok damn I really thought it was I
really thought it was like a subtitles I
mean there might be a subtitle uh but no
it's actually the empire was the old
books yeah but I anyway yeah yeah okay
um so you've always seen him as evil
even after reading no no no not from
there he's like straight up though
but yeah no uh I'm saying that the the
strongest um uh connection I I did have
was via Rebels where they played him
very much like a villain yeah and I was
hoping that was adapting him to live
action that we would get more of that
Nuance um from like the books that
you've read or from the commentary that
I I that I was hoping they they would
bring that and here it seems like
they're pretty much just leaning
villainy uh I I think that is it could
be a very well done misdirection
um
I think I think he is number one I think
you can still be a villain I.E the
Soviets and like fight against the worst
evil eye even Nazis like yeah
that being said doesn't make you less of
a villain you're still a villain you
just happen to be on the right side I
think that whatever they're running away
from in this galaxy is ultimately the
a big big villain and that has always
been thrawn's motivation as a character
yeah that is the he's like Collective
like the reason he he became part of the
Empire the reason that he did over
everything that he did I think his
mistrust for the Jedi is like not
necessarily misplaced no in that like
you know like with friends with Anakin
how'd that work out like well and he
also judges based off of history and
lineage and um one mention of art here
you son of a that's why he's mad
that's why he wants to leave there's no
art yeah we can't learn anything all
these statues have big mouths that it's
making me it's really uncomfortable
um yeah I like but overall I like Lars
Nicholson's performance and uh obviously
it was funny
sounded sensitive because he's very
Throne is usually portrayed as uh you
know buff no very scary skinny um
there's a scrappy little skin he's gone
this is a well-fed throwing and yeah
he's a well a little little belly's got
there
um however I kind of like it for the
updated portrayal especially upon his
introduction when you get that profile
shot like oh he's found a way to kind of
make it work yeah a little bit a little
bit luxurious and I'd rather get the
performance of Lars more than anything
else that is kind of I think the best
argument there but I also think that he
probably just has a little belly and I
mean yeah white doesn't look good on
anybody after Labor Day I'm saying that
I think people will bring it up yeah and
I'm saying I actually think it kind of
works yes I'm for it uh and okay so we
got that and then uh but Ezra Bridger as
I'm
so happy uh I I just think the casting
was perfect I was so worried that he was
going to be wearing his Rebels outfit
and was going to look cyst like he looks
so bad in the Hologram and I was so
scared that that was like what we were
going to see and instead we got this
like entirely new look that still felt
Jedi
um but also felt so different uh
instantly instantly his chemistry uh
with Sabine was just like oh sorry
straight plucked out yeah which is the
back and forth which honestly like
I'm really like a circus last episode
really kind of solidified
um just the growth and I was really
hoping this episode would do it for me
um for Sabine I still haven't seen it
I'm hoping a little bit more time with
Ezra and the two of them in their
Dynamic might give us something but I'm
I'm beginning to think maybe I just
don't like
job like which stinks because I loved
her character in Rebels
um but the live action portrayal just
has not been doing it for me but I
thought the build up to Ezra was great
it was also just like a really nice
juxtaposition from like Angry like like
hermit Luke
um and to get like oh no he was like
happy Ezra still being Ezra yeah still
true to himself
um just a little bit older a little bit
wiser yeah I mean he's wise he's much
wiser I mean uh especially he seems like
it he seems a little bit more Sage which
I really do you look a little bit more
Sage than you used to but I wouldn't say
you're any wiser than you were when we
first really sure I mean I haven't been
stranded
it usually leads to some cool mystery
and wisdom as you've seen in Castaway
yeah what was in those boxes so I yeah I
I like I like the little bit that we got
there uh it really felt like as as a
bridge or but growing up
thank you
and yeah to me I did I I I'm not in love
with the Sabine performance this was my
favorite performance of hers because I
liked her back and forth with Ron yeah
and I like her Dynamic with throm is
really uh the strongest her engagement
with the uh creatures I thought was
really good too I loved her fight scene
um and especially with that final moment
with with Ezra that was like yeah that's
my this is my favorite episode of her uh
specifically the live action one but
then again John I'm gonna throw you here
on Ezra Bridger as the build up and not
really having familiarity with him
um did it make an impression of sorts
like what's your honest take on on here
is a is your whatever position
um no it was a lovely introduction
because it was a ray of Hope and uh I
don't know there was something about the
actor there's something about this actor
showing up and especially joking about
like I don't know you know you start to
play the math and the and the game of
these shows and be like oh what are they
gonna hold on to what are they gonna
know and uh for everything that has come
before it again I thought it was a
genuinely bright Ray to kind of cut
through everything and to be like oh
what a relief and also here's a guy who
you know it doesn't hurt that I have a
new character who's also not very dour
at the moment to you know learn about
and to catch up to and that's the
reminder Point hey guys
I almost forgot
um it is uh oh no don't lose it crackers
it's been a few days guys you don't know
what's been going on in my life uh okay
the
they keep okay there's a lot of this
conversation about this planet and oh
there's like dark Forces here and it's
threatening and then you got like the
witches and and you keep you know
there's a lot of emphasis too I think
you guys remember going this was like
emphasis too on thrawn like we gotta
jump ship out of here you know uh but
what I love with Ezra
um was there's an as as uh Sabine is
searching for him she encounters
creatures where there is such light
generated from that you know such joy
and then even with Ezra he's managed to
find beauty here
um and it's it's a great representation
of Darkseid and Light Side yeah and I
think they really capture that tonality
and just the overall Spirit of this is
not just you know pretty it's not just
this like evil graveyard there there is
beauty here and Ezra managed to find it
whilst being a nomad yeah and so I think
that was a really strong thing they
captured here which they could have so
easily gone the opposite direction yeah
because he's down he could have been uh
like on a mountain not wanting to see
your lightsaber yeah like that's but
actually and and I I think that's one of
my favorite things about Ezra as just a
character in general like
his like date of birth was literally the
beginning of the Empire like his entire
existence has been marred by like these
dark times and yet despite losing his
parents despite losing his master
despite getting stranded in a different
galaxy he has always been able to
maintain hope and light and I think
represents the best of what the old Jedi
was right
um and in so many ways what the new Jedi
can be and I think for both Sabine
somebody who from the very beginning who
grew up in the same exact times and has
experienced all that that dour and hurt
and kind of retreated Inward and caught
herself off from the force and even
Ahsoka whom I think has been on this
really powerful Journey especially in
the last episode
Ezra is going to be such an important
reminder
of
not just the light but also
the potential and that there is a
Futures exactly which is what all the
characters need and honestly what I'm
really curious about maybe it's what
balen needs it seems like it's where
it's headed man I mean he's he's such a
and it also really seems like I know
you're doing a transition here uh it
also seems like thrawn like Throne
doesn't need to dispose of Ezra if
they're just going to leave especially
when he's saying like just so you know
if you if we leave and you're not on
that ship you're going to be stranded
here
see so he doesn't need to dispose of
them so it seems like he's got a I mean
I can imagine he's kind of mad at us
now now they've got now they've got the
pergil uh so he might not feel that way
I mean he probably feels that I mean no
no the soak on the pro but prior to that
I'm saying yeah yeah it seems like he
has a like he's got a personal Vendetta
against Ezra I it I think it's both the
Vendetta and an admiration I mean I
think that's what my favorite part of
thrawn is he doesn't just view his
enemies his enemies he views him as
people uh who are complex and
sophisticated and Ezra to outmatch him
as like you know a little boy it must
Fascinate him in a yeah uh your bailing
poem what were you I love what they're
teasing with Bailon because what I love
what they're doing balen is they seem
like they're really setting up
I love how I'm not feeling like this is
going nowhere in the sense of
uh we're just building to the first
order or some right even though
he's talking about that essentially he's
like right rise and fall you know the
Empire he's like it's like something
interesting about this guy but but it
seems like what he is searching for here
which they have not clarified you have a
very clear Theory you've mentioned a few
times of where they're possibly going
with this
I still feel like whatever it is
specifically a bailin is seeking that's
leading us let's open up a new door for
us in Star Wars the most it's
specifically his character that's just
the inkling that I'm at least yeah well
I I think the
if
if they go the direction of of the the
first order and and all of that and try
to tie this on I honestly think they'd
be doing a giant disservice too orange
everything that they've done no I think
where this is going if and and it will
be a miracle if they can pull it off
you have
all these different elements of the
force in in terms of Palin Ahsoka Ezra
Sabine
um
no but between them all there's there is
a collective knowledge and spectrum of
the force that I wouldn't necessarily
say is on the dark side but represents
a a Nuance
Balin is a crusader
of a bygone era who was disillusioned by
what happened to his order Ahsoka is a
crusader from a bygone area who is
they have the opportunity here in my
mind to be both General the the front
line and and and the first defense for
the Galaxy against whatever this greater
evil is going to be whether it be the
the grisk of of the books and the comics
or whether it be something that we've
never seen before and I think all of
them coming together and reconciling
that the force is a spectrum
um and that to achieve balance there
there has to be somewhere in between
there needs to be you know I I think it
will create a fascinating New Jedi Order
that can exist outside of of the Galaxy
that we know and that maybe can be
reconnected with you know what they're
hoping to do with the ray series and her
building her new Jedi Order
um but I
I hope that they don't
they don't just bring these characters
back to the old Galaxy and and
put them on a collision course with
seven eight nine uh at least I I hope
that they they give them
they have a whole new Galaxy right for
storytelling oh yeah so
um but John which is a death Amir yeah
which is so excited I mean they're not
witches of bathroom here
they're the dathomiri which is of Old
Death Amir yes so some combination of
these yeah they're the Benny just I know
you are but what am I
yeah they're the fates of the betting
Jesuit they're the weird sisters if they
were any more on the nose
I mean I just cannot wait like this is
all getting very heavy metal if they're
gonna have like some kind of witch
Showdown on some Bone have you seen any
of which is the bathroom mirror little
bits and pieces yeah what does that
means
the witches of death mirror I would have
only seen in like breakdown footage okay
uh there are other things that I've seen
in actual episodes but they're uh not
them
so I mean like
the idea alone gets me excited because
that's just something very much up my
alley Ancient Order of which is I would
love to see how that applies to this and
those I feel like recent Star Wars has
been dogged with uh at least in life
actually my question is yeah what'd you
think of their what do you think of
their um the impression that they left I
mean I was I was very intrigued by
everything they're perhaps the element
that rests the least on good casting for
me like it's just a generally
interesting idea and as being that we
are in this ancient part of the Galaxy
that feels very ancient it feels like
you know Middle Earth ruins or something
like that they feel like characters who
just naturally would root there and I
would love some kind of exploration
especially because we have had enough
investment in Morgan ellsbeth at least
to bring her out of Mando into this show
and extrapolate on that
um I just as a on my wish list would
love some kind of diver for them to
factor in heavily and for that aspect of
this world that seems like it's kind of
lost or fringed now to you know rear its
ugly head again especially because we do
live in a moment where uh metaphysics
and mysticism are more prominent in the
mainstream and I feel like you know Star
Wars of old is commenting on a certain
period of War as it is also bringing in
certain film Aesthetics so I feel like
this could be an interesting way to
further update I mean like you know I
feel like you should look beyond the
spectrum of you know into the broader
spectrum of Wars for your inspiration
for this instead of just always doing
the Nazis over and over again
um but yeah this is well you know
actually
Vietnam was also a big part of it sure
yeah it sure was no yeah I mean
I I agree though with John on that like
I feel like the show is at risk of
sometimes it seems like they put out
was like oh this is the planet this is
lore backstory yeah then Star Wars fans
will extrapolate that you know down
they'll they'll they'll dilute it down
to it's like finest mineral but we won't
with the show itself won't do anything
with its characters sure and I feel like
that's the risk that we have with it
it's like yeah they introduced lore cool
but nothing really became of it
emotional wise or story wise and that is
my that is my my concern that it won't
do anything and it's more of us just you
know our thumbs waiting for it to be I'm
not saying he's gonna do that yeah I'm
just saying that that is one concern
that's a super valid concern yeah and my
my big hope here is that uh in uh Jedi
Survivor
that was my favorite of them I like them
more than Clone Wars yeah just because I
think it's because you actually like run
around death yeah uh Jedi Survivor in
particular and how they captured the
relation between a Jedi and a witch of
death Amir
um paints such a
like if if this is all working towards
like the Star Wars equivalent of an end
game taking like the magic of dathomir
taking the power of the force of the
light and the dark because there is an
enemy that is greater than the whole of
all of those is something that really
really excites me and I think also just
it would be really nice for once to just
kind of flip the good and bad on its
head and I've like they're the closest
they've ever been to successfully doing
that
um and I think Balin is just like the
perfect representation of that but even
Morgan's character to an extent is
there's a lot of like Nuance in her
performance I don't want to like give
her the benefit of any doubt but like
there is a
I'm I'm putting my faith in the in the
writers and Dave filoni in particular
that they're not just going to use like
The Witches of dathomir to bring them to
this Galaxy and then to just not
conclude that Arc but also what the heck
happened to The Witches of dathomir in
this galaxy it seems worth exploring not
to be like rip off dude more but like
you know there is such a rich well in
that story with Benny Jester and all
that stuff and the amount of Sway and
just the part of the bigger political
spectrum they can occupy and I think
that would be a really cool interesting
thing that has been trodden but is very
much new in the live action setting and
I do feel like if they
I don't know what their plan is for this
new Galaxy and I you brought some one of
you said something earlier which is you
know I hope they don't just use this as
an excuse to collect up a couple
characters bring them back to the main
timeline then go right into you know the
sequel trailers yeah Greg that was a
great point and it's that thing you
reminded me to tell you to say right
um like that's these are all things
where yeah I'm waiting to see if there
will be window dressing or not because
if they never really bother to expound
on this galaxy again I'll feel kind of
let down I'll feel kind of and and two I
mean we are at that point where I'm like
okay cool we're in this new place like
you said we're kind of on one planet and
it's a wreck it's a ruin it's a derelict
yeah what is the rest of this place look
like and how different can it be and in
some ways it is like oh well you know
how much do you show and dispel that
mysticism or you know it could be a cool
opportunity to really try out some new
things some new Aesthetics some new
stories some new something yeah and I
feel like that is something that
new Star Wars has been trying to figure
out really desperately I think like when
they when it's the thing is if there's
one criticism I do actually have that
just didn't pop into my head till right
now sure before we entered the planet
they were saying how oh man
uh that we were talking about is that um
the before we enter they're like oh I
mean I like the additional Lord that
they gave us in the per Gil and how
that's connected to
um you know the the witches I thought
that was really cool to get
is they were setting up like how it's a
graveyard and stuff and I felt like
there was going to be like this menacing
horror almost almost equivalent to
something like two towers into uh or
something something a bit more
apocalyptic yeah and I feel like when we
travel to death in me yeah if that feels
more horrifying then
here you know and I was like oh I kind
of wish we got some of that part of part
of me wonders if they're they're saving
some of that I like I kind of want to
like and this is just like Michael in
Fantasyland at this point but I want I
don't think we're gonna get a giant
satisfying conclusion at the end of this
season I feel like it's going to be an
Empire Strikes Back situation I yeah
it's it's gonna be a big but it's not
going to be like a satisfying conclusion
to this Arc what I want to see is
dividing on the planet and then Jordan's
gonna I want to see them on the front
lines of like
oh this is like bad of of whatever this
big bad is and to see a planet that's
just been absolutely devastated and to
realize that the threat that thrawn is
running away from
is going to find its way to their Galaxy
yeah they're that last line of defense I
would strand everybody here at the end
of the season yeah I I I I think we got
a lot to unpack yes we move forward what
do you guys think yeah I would love to
I'd love to know
um and theorize with you uh
but guys this was great
um friends if you enjoyed this
if you enjoyed this fire the tenacity
like I gotta wrap this up like
I'm gonna wrap it up
every single time
oh to leave a like and a comment
make sure you hit the the Bell button we
should shout someone out we should shout
somebody out is it um is it those names
right there yeah yeah the to-do's not
the completes uh Hey Gabriel Gabriel
yeah Gabriel the archangel oh no oh no
you get done it now he hates that
everyone is not an angel we've done that
child so many times he's expressed that
he is not believing God more to him than
that Gabriel the
antichrists
already with another shot Gabriel you
gotta see every man yeah Gabriel
long for Gabe
you know I've been watching uh the
office uh finally uh I I realized I
never made a pass season eight because I
was I didn't want to let Michael Scott
go and there's a character on there who
I know a lot of people don't really like
his name is Gabe yeah and um as I've
been watching the show I gotta say I
don't get the hate for Gabe I think
Gabe's an all right guy and I imagine
this Gabriel is kind of like you buddy
even better
so you just lanky and
um a little bit insecure that was the
name of it
lanky a little bit insecure and uh kind
of trying to posture confidence but it's
never quite really there I had posture
once and then that's why uh you insist
on never mentioning the Archangel
element not believer in God very much
gave from the office uh so I that's kind
of my Association and but funny funny
guy at the same time I have no idea what
your physical appearance looks like one
time I made a shout out about someone's
physical appearance not knowing what
they look like and I even stayed at that
and they got severely offended yeah and
I said I don't even know you look like
I'm clearly just making up on the
spot here so you might be like super fat
for all I know
um or you could be like a dwarf uh I
don't know which way you go buddy
um you could be disfigured
you could just be a head in a jar either
way Futurama a disfigured fat dwarf a
dis figure oh that people must point at
you a lot
I mean I get it sometimes
[Music]
embrace the shout out we love you
Gabriel love you Gabe you know it's all
in fun see you buddy